what we
got don't be scared come on hey hey um I
guess just for you take another look at
what the bench was able to do tonight I
think 43 points from the bench just what
kind of energy do they bring
tonight
um want the hul Hulk Voice or yanis
voice let's go this boys um no I feel
like the with the second unit the ball
was moving uh guys was getting involved
uh a lot of energy um cam was uh
unbelievable today offensively
defensively Bobby was being Bobby
brought energy physicality made shots
for us gets us going uh we just you know
in the second unit we like we cannot
hold the ball we just want to move the
ball get everybody involved get to our
spots make sure PC gets involved and
gets open shots Mar wasn't play today
Mar uh big key in the second unit of
like making as tough as possible for
whoever uh he guarding because
defensively is is um he's a nightmare uh
and offensively he crash crash the
boards all the time makes play for
himself shoots open threes so coming in
in the second un I feel like in in this
game like brought so much energy for us
and we got to keep on doing that not
just for this game for the next game too
like this is what the second unit does
we don't we don't we try to get
everybody involved we don't try to do it
ourselves and it's it's a good it's a
good feeli it's a good Rhythm and we got
to keep it going